FRANK: Mark, what about the
Mobile Oil signs.
One stand's been homemade.
You've got a rim on
the bottom of it.
MARK: Yeah, model A rim.
FRANK: What would you
have to have for them?
That one right there,
I'd want about 1,500.
1,500?
What about-- what would
you do on the pair?
I mean, 15, I
think, is up there.
MARK: Thing is they
got [inaudible] stuff--
you go to those flea
markets and stuff, probably,
like, 2,800 for both of them.
- 2,800?
Yeah.
Uh, Dad, I don't
want to sell them.
I gotta-- you
gotta leave a little.
I was thinking 2,000 for both.
We'll keep them for that.
Frank wanted both.
I go no way.
Yeah.
No.
What's the best on
the one with the rim?
1,300.
1,300, yeah-- let me
see the back of it here.
JIMMY: I think we got
a base laying around,
an original base somewhere.
The base is important.
It's on a rim right now.
That doesn't do it any justice.
Well, if I pay 13 for this, how
much is the base if we find it?
Probably at least--
MARK: 150.
150.
That's what I was thinking--
FRANK: For the base?
--150 bucks more.
I mean, because it's
the original base.
It's somewhere in here.
FRANK (VOICEOVER): If
I can find the base,
we can have the rim cut off,
have the pipe re-threaded,
and then have it put
on the original stand.
1,300, and you guys will
try to help me find the base.
- Yes.
And we find the base,
it's good condition,
a buck and a half.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- All right.
MARK: OK.
FRANK: Got a deal.
MARK: All right.
All right now.
FRANK: You got it.
FRANK (VOICEOVER):
1,300 is up there.
But I wanted to get
some money going.
I wanted to get something
going with these people
so they know we're
serious on buying.
Mike, when you're
crawling around,
you're looking for a
mobile cast iron base.
All right, so there's
a base in here somewhere?
- Yeah.
All right, what else
you got back here?
FRANK (VOICEOVER): So me
and Mike kind of separate.
I go with Jimmy.
He goes with Mark.
How about this, Jimmy?
This battery charging station.
He'd put the batteries on here.
They'd be for sale.
It's enamel.
It's not porcelain or
anything like that.
- No, I want to keep that one.
- You want to keep it?
All right.
- Yeah.
I can understand.
MIKE (VOICEOVER): The
last time we were here,
we didn't even deal with Jimmy.
He was younger then.
We were dealing
with the old man.
Red crown?
- Not for sale.
- NFS?
JIMMY: Yes, sir.
MIKE (VOICEOVER): So it's
kind of cool to watch Jimmy
and Frank try to make a deal.
What about that?
"Pollution Control"?
JIMMY: Naw, I'll
probably keep that.
FRANK: Keep that too?
JIMMY: Yeah, it
looks nice up there.
I might need that.
- You might need that?
- Yeah.
FRANK: What about the
Firestone, would you sell that?
JIMMY: Mm-mm, no.
FRANK: You know we gotta ask.
JIMMY: Yep.
- That's a nice light.
What about that light?
MARK: Yeah, will I sell that?
Let me see the end.
It's off an old
lathe or something?
- Mm-hmm.
- What do you get for that?
Give me 30 bucks for it.
All right, I'll do it.
- All right.
- Have to rewire it.
We'll work it out.
- Yeah.
What about the Imperial
and the Cypress sign?
No, probably hang onto that.
- Hang onto that one?
- Yeah.
East Cypress.
FRANK: 300 bucks?
No.
No?
I'll keep that.
FRANK (VOICEOVER):
I'm starting to think
Jimmy's freezing me out.
I bought a really cool Sunset
Boulevard street sign from Mark
last time we were here.
But Jimmy won't even listen to
a price on street signs today.
What about this sign,
would you sell that?
MARK: Yeah.
MIKE (VOICEOVER):
This is a porcelain
speed limit sign that
has plastic reflectors
in the numbers.
MIKE: Would you do 350 on this?
[ca-ching]
If this were older, it
would have glass reflectors.
But let's face it.
When it's up on the wall,
it's still going to look good.
FRANK: Jimmy, what
about the Miller tires?
JIMMY: No, I'm keeping that.
FRANK: How about the Texaco?
JIMMY: Nope.
MIKE (VOICEOVER): I'm
dealing with Mark.
And I'm hearing what's going
on with Frank around the room.
FRANK: This is called a
Junior Harley-Davidson,
made by Hubley.
JIMMY: No.
FRANK: How about your Valvoline?
FRANK: How about the clock?
JIMMY: Na, I'll keep that.
MIKE: I'm hearing
Frank ask about things.
It's like, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
No no no.
No.
FRANK: Let's see where
your-- see where Pops is at.
I mean, you just gotta--
you gotta keep trying.
You gotta keep trying.
Mark, what about this one?
There's not a lot
of color left on it.
JIMMY: Not for sale.
That's the only one we got.
FRANK (VOICEOVER): Now, I
know I'm not being paranoid.
I remember this exact sign
from the last time I was here.
What do you get for
something like this?
MARK: 75 bucks.
FRANK: 75?
MARK: Yep.
I'm just going to
keep looking here.
I'm going to keep--
- OK.
FRANK (VOICEOVER): We
always say the time to buy
is when you see it.
And here's proof of that.
But more importantly,
the time to buy it
is when you first
see it with Mark.
FRANK: What about
the Shell clam shell
over here that's kind of rusty?
JIMMY: Nnnnope.
FRANK: All right.
Things were going great
when we first stopped in.
And then, all of a
sudden, it shut down.
I mean, it turned off
like a light switch.
What do you got on
the Coca Cola sign?
JIMMY: No.
FRANK: Hey, what's
this now, guys?
What's this?
Here's the base right here!
JIMMY: There it is.
And of all people, you found it.
When Frank bought
that sign, I was
hoping he didn't find the base.
- 150?
- We got it.
All right.
FRANK (VOICEOVER): All I need
to do is cut the rim off,
have it threaded, put it on.
It raises it by hundreds.
All right, I'm excited.